But now the important thing is this. Just because I have given you 1 example
where greedy works extremely well doesn't mean that this algorithm will perform well
on any network. We haven't yet proven that it has a good approximation quality.
And a good way to test approximation quality is to always try and construct an input
for which the algorithm will perform really, really bad. So basically we are now
going to try and trick this algorithm here--the greedy algorithm--into picking
suboptimal vertices, basically using this greedy strategy against it. And if we do this
basically using this greedy strategy against it, that will give us some indication on
where this algorithm could fail and how badly it could fail. So if it's
a factor 2 approximation algorithm, if it's a factor 1.5 approximation algorithm maybe,
or if it's actually not a good approximation algorithm at all although it sounds good.
And of course this is similar to some of the problems we have already had
in this course. Finding out how to trick this algorithm, that takes a bit of playing around.
So next to the screen here I have lying about 4 or 5 sheets of paper on which I
experimented around to find out how I could trick this algorithm, and whenever you
want to trick an approximation algorithm, it just takes a bit of time to sink your teeth
into that. But here is something that I have come up with, and it's very similar
of course to the ideas that other people have also had to try and trick the greedy
algorithm. So I'll start out with the amazing number of 24 vertices. Now as if this
weren't enough, I will now add 12 additional vertices. You can now see why I
used up so much paper playing around with this. And then I'm going to connect them
like this. Now my question to you is, how many vertices would greedy choose
if we gave it this graph here as an input? And please enter your answer here.